In this lecture, we're going to be talking about URLs
and the encoding of requests.
So a URL, as you've probably seen before
in typing in your browser,
is composed of a number of things.
So it is composed of a scheme, a host, a port,
a path, a query, and a fragment.
So let's take as an example, this request right here,
or rather this URL right here.
And a URL is a uniform resource locator
for those wondering,
but most people call them just URLs.
So in this case, we have some example.com
requesting a kind of a cat.gif with some width, some height,
and then we can pretend for this example
that let's say we're kind of also requesting
that the gif be played two seconds into its duration.
So this first thing here is HTTP.
And within the context of a URL,
you might have a number of different protocols.
So all sorts of protocols use a URL scheme
that looks very similar.
So we need to basically specify
what is the protocol being used to access this resource?
Well, in the case of HTTP,
the Hypertext Transport Protocol,
we're using HTTP as our protocol for accessing the resource.
The next thing is the host.
So the host defines where this resource is being held.
So in this case, we're saying,
hey, there's some server out there on the internet
that we call example.com, and it holds this resource.
Now, the next thing is the port.
And the port is going to be,
if we think back to the internet lecture,
the transport layer basically defines that,
hey, a server might have several services,
several programs running on it,
and each of them might be facilitating
different network applications.
Not all of them might be speaking HTTP.
They might be speaking different application protocols
on top of there.
But in this case, we're looking at port 80,
which is the standard HTTP protocol.
Alternatively, we might have multiple web servers
running on the same host.
So for instance, we might have a web server
running on port 80, another website,
or web server rather, on example.com running on port 8080.
And we might need to specify different ports
for accessing those different web servers.
By default though, a normal use case within the internet,
or within the World Wide Web rather, is port 80.
And that can be optionally left out,
but this is the full URL scheme.
So the next thing is the path.
So the path identifies the specific resource
that we're trying to either get or interact with,
again, thinking back to get request, post request,
the resource that we're trying to interact with.
So in this case, cat.gif.
The next part of the URL scheme is the query.
So we might basically be saying,
hey, this resource has other information
that it might need in order to know
how to correctly get that resource,
or if we're interacting with that resource,
how we want to interact with that resource.
So for example, we can imagine that this web server
is able to facilitate this cat.gif resource,
and it might be able to return GIFs
of different widths and heights.
So in this case, we specify within the query,
hey, I want a width of 256 and a height of 256.
And again, it's really up to the web application
to be how it's going to facilitate these requests,
but this is what the standardized URL scheme
supports for communication,
and this is how things are standardized.
So again, this is information that the resource can use
for kind of figuring out a little more information
about that resource.
And then the last thing is the fragment.
So the fragment actually isn't sent out
in our networked request.
It is client-specific information.
So the programs that we're interacting with,
so for instance, let's say we're using our web browser
to facilitate this request,
the web browser might want its own information.
So for instance, let's say we pass this link
along to someone else,
and we're specifically interested in this cat.gif
at the two-second mark within the GIF,
and we don't want them to see the first two seconds,
well, we can actually pass along this full URL
with client-side information.
In this case, we're imagining that our browser
is going to be able to start playing the cat.gif video
at the two-second mark.
And this fragment component allows for a URL
to contain client-specific information about the resource
that isn't actually passed along to the server.
Okay, so let's recall back to the request URI
from the previous lecture video on RFC 1945.
So we have this request line that's composed of our method,
our request URI, and this HTTP version.
So the request URI is a critical component of the URL
and kind of gets translated in this request.
But there's something to think about here
when we're accessing a request.
The thing to think about is that what happens
if I want to get the hello space world resource?
We have a little bit of an issue here,
which is that if I was to go and make this request,
the server is actually going to inform me that,
hey, you made a bad request.
And what that means, as we saw in the RFC 1945 lecture video
is that you are not actually speaking valid HTTP.
The server understands that you're asking for something,
but it doesn't know what you're speaking
because it can't properly parse this HTTP request
that you've made.
You've made a bad request.
And the reason for that is these spaces in the request line.
So we have method, space, request URI, space, HTTP version,
and then carriage return line feed.
These spaces are delimiting the start
and the end of the request URI.
So when we went and we put a space in there,
the server, when it goes to parse this,
is gonna see, hey, I'm requesting the slash hello resource.
And then my HTTP version is world, right?
Which isn't an HTTP version.
And the parsing has gotten out of sync
and it's a massive issue.
The solution to this problem, however, is encoding.
So we need some sort of way of basically saying,
I want hello space world, that resource,
because for whatever reason,
we might imagine that we need our web application
to facilitate web resources that have a space in it.
There's no reason to leave them out,
that that shouldn't be possible.
Though, I mean, I guess in theory,
you could imagine a protocol where you just aren't allowed
to have resources with spaces in them.
But fortunately, HTTP allows for resources
with spaces in them.
URLs can have spaces in them.
They just must be encoded.
So there are a number of unsafe characters,
which includes, for instance, that space.
And it's unsafe, as we saw,
because when we go to parse that request,
it's gonna throw off the parser.
I mean, in theory, you could write a parser
that could deal with it,
but we want things to be very simple, quick,
and we have defined in the standard
that the space character is unsafe and must be encoded.
There's also some reserved characters that must be encoded.
And then there's also unprintable characters
that must be encoded.
So for example, if our resource
had a newline character in it,
how would we represent that in the URL?
I mean, I guess you could imagine having this URL written out
and then a new line in it, and it goes to a second line.
It'd be a little strange looking, a little confusing.
It could work, but according to the standard,
those are unprintable characters and they must be encoded.
Optionally, though, all characters may be encoded.
So if you want to encode, let's say, an A,
you're free to do so.
It's just not a requirement that it be encoded.
So what do these encodings look like then?
Well, the way that these characters are encoded
is that we have a percent sign
followed by a hex character followed by a hex character.
So we're going off of the ASCII chart here on the right
for determining what those hex character values are.
And if we look here at space in,
let's see here, where is the space character?
In the top row, second column, we have our,
or third column rather, we have the space character
and its hex value in ASCII is two zero.
So the way that we URL encode that character
is that we say it is percent two zero.
Alternatively, pound is percent two three,
slash is percent two F, question mark is percent three F.
And again, we can optionally choose to encode
any of the characters using this URL encoding scheme.
We can do percent four one for capital A.
So then now let's see what that looks like
when we make a correctly formed request
for the hello space world resource.
Instead of putting a space there,
we put that percent two zero.
We've correctly URL encoded our request
and now the web server is happy with us
and is happy to return to us the hello space world resource.
Okay, so there are a number of encoding methods.
So we were looking there at the URL encoding,
but there's a number of content types for servicing requests
especially in the context of let's say posting data.
So we saw earlier in a previous lecture video
that we might want to have some form on our website
in which we're specifying, hey, my name is Connor
and I want to post the fact that my name is Connor
to the greet resource.
This is kind of what this request here is specifying.
So in this case, we declared to the web server,
hey, we're using a content type of application
X www form URL encoded.
And what that means and what that structure looks like
is that we can have a number of fields
where each field is represented with its key.
So in this case, name, and then its value,
in this case, Connor,
and they are separated with an equal sign.
We could also have more values in there
and those other values would be separated with an ampersand.
Okay, alternatively though,
we don't have to just use a form URL encoded content type.
We can also use a JSON encoded content type
for speaking to it.
And there are reasons why you might choose
one over the other.
In this case, JSON is JavaScript object notation.
So this allows us to send
kind of slightly more structured data at a server.
And in this case, it looks something like this
where we have some curly braces,
we specify our key within quotes,
and then we say that we have this string object Connor
after a colon, and this is the structure of JSON.
The use cases for both vary.
It's up to the web application
for what kinds of content types it's gonna be looking for.
So some might have, for example,
that form URL encoded as a result of the fact
that you're interacting with a form on a webpage
and you go and let's say, click some submit button.
So you can imagine a form
where you're asked to type in your name
and then you hit submit,
and it posts as a form URL encoded content type
to the server and the server is looking
for that content type and it's gonna go through
and understand that.
On the other hand, you might have
more hierarchical data that the server
wants to be able to handle.
And we might be building up these complex objects
that we want to send to the server
and you might choose to use application JSON.
One common paradigm within the world wide web,
within the web is JSON RESTful APIs.
You might have heard of that.
And what that is, is these programming layer basically
of I want to interact with this remote server
and I want to start making requests
that we don't necessarily care about HTML.
We don't care about these webpages.
We just want to be doing kind of remote computation.
We want to be making these API requests out to the server,
getting API responses back that we can do on top of HTTP.
And oftentimes they might use the JSON content type
for doing that.
That's kind of why that exists.
It's a very common scheme to basically be pushing data
with JSON, the server can very quickly parse
this complex hierarchical structure
and then return complex results that aren't HTTP,
that aren't meant to be viewed in the browser,
or rather HTML that aren't meant to be viewed
in the browser, but are instead just blobs of data
that have structure to them.
And that's why you might use the JSON content type.